Netanyahu has visited Gaza his office
released video showing him
congratulating soldiers it's the first
time a prime minister from Israel has
been inside Gaza in nearly 20
years okay well let's go and get the
view now from occupied East Jerusalem
Imran Khan is there and Imran we just
saying there a significant move by
Benjamin Netanyahu to make this visit to
to Gaza I mean clearly this photo op was
something that Netanyahu just simply
couldn't miss
that's absolutely it he wanted to be
seen in Gaza not just in Gaza but
surrounded by Israeli military forces he
wore a flat jacket in Israeli military
colors he wore that helmet and he spoke
to people this the first time an Israeli
Prime Minister has been to Gaza since
they disengaged in
2005 so it's a it's a landmark visit for
that but what he said when he was there
is actually worth repeating repeting he
said we're making every effort to return
our hostages and eventually we will
return them all we have three goals for
this war eliminating Hamas returning all
our hostages and ensuring that Gaza does
not become a threat to the state of
Israel again we will continue until the
end until Victory nothing will stop us
and we're convinced that we have the
power the strength and the will and the
determination to achieve all the war's
goals and we will now we've heard Prim
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu say things
like this before but not in this Loc
this location in Gaza was what he wants
the Israeli public to see this is very
much a message to the Israeli public a
domestic message uh reiterating the fact
that he is a tough prime minister and
that he's the only prime minister that
be able to lead Israel out of uh this
latest crisis and deal with Hamas in the
way that he keeps talking about this
wasn't about the words uh this was
simply about the location and him being
seen there and it will be seen like that
uh within Israeli Society people will
look at Prime Minister
Benjamin prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and say to themselves wow our
prime minister is there things must be
going well and that's the message he
wants to be delivered and in terms of um
controlling the narrative Imran the isi
government has been Keen to control
precisely that scenes of celebration
around the release of Palestinian
prisoners what are their
concerns well there's only really one
person that's driving all of this is the
national security minister itar Ben G
now he is uncompromising when it comes
to the Palestinians he simply doesn't
have a decent word to say about any of
them his public statements are openly
racist and he's been like this uh for a
very long time he's worried uh that the
Palestinians particularly here in
occupied East Jerusalem remember he
controls the police force so he's able
to have a lot more say on what the
police do here in occupied EAS Jerusalem
he said to them that celebrations need
to be cracked down upon and that any
celebrations are tantamount to
supporting terrorism now it seemingly
that has actually happened here in
occupied e RM aler has been speaking to
families here they've shared their
concerns they're worried if they speak
to the media is that being seen as
celebrating uh a you a release um and
that's something that they're worried
about but he also said that he wanted
the Army who contr control the occupied
West Bank to do the same uh in those
territories that really hasn't happened
you saw my colleague nidada there uh
speaking to people who have just been uh
released from prison uh they are there
they're saying that look we are people
are out uh so there seems to be a
disconnect between what he can do here
in occupied East Jerusalem because he is
nominally in charge of the police force
but he's not in charge of the Army in
the occupied West Bank and they seem to
be um ignoring a large part of what he's
saying although you did see those
pictures there there is certainly a
Crackdown taking place on the
Palestinians in the occupied West Bank
yeah there is indeed plumes of tear gas
The vuna Crossing there Imran Khan many
thanks for the update Imran Khan in
occupied East Jerusalem